[Musik]
hallo ihr leben in diesem video zeige
ich euch das grundrezept für meinen keks
teig den mache ich das ganze jahr über
für verschiedene anlässe
denn ich mache meistens motiv kekse
draus wir benötigen 330 gramm mehl 140
gramm zucker 180 gramm weiche butter 1
ei der größe m
eine prise salz und fünf gramm
backpulver
die weiche butter wird mit dem zucker
und dem salz mit hilfe des ruhr hakens
der küchenmaschine geschmeidig gerührt
natürlich geht das ganze auch ohne
küchenmaschine dann könnte auch einfach
den handmixer benutzen
[Musik]
nach zirka einer minute wird dann auch
das all untergerührt und da müsst ihr
einfach so lange rühren bis sich das ei
verbunden hat und nicht länger
[Musik]
anschließend geben wir die trockenen
zutaten hinzu also einmal das mehl und
das backpulver und hier ist es ganz
wichtig dass die zutaten gesiebt werden
damit auch keine klümpchen entstehen
[Musik]
das ganze wird dann noch einmal
miteinander verrührt da wird aber keinen
blätterteig entstehen da kommt erst mal
so eine krümelige masse zustande
und dann müssen wir mit den händen
weitermachen
[Musik]
dafür wird der teig auf die saubere
arbeitsfläche gegeben und so lange mit
den händen geknetet bis ein glatter teig
entsteht
ich benutze dafür am liebsten meine
handschuhe denn auch wenn man die nägel
nicht so lang sind hat man doch so ein
bisschen teig ist der monte den nägeln
und das finde ich ziemlich unangenehm
[Musik]
und da müsste jetzt auch nicht so
unendlich lange kneten also wenn sich
der teig verbunden hat ungefähr so
aussieht dann könnte ihn in
frischhaltefolie einwickeln und zum
kühlen in den kühlschrank legen
[Musik]
eingewickelte teil kommt jetzt für ca 4
stunden in den kühlschrank ich habe auch
schon mal drei stunden im kühlschrank
gelassen das war eigentlich auch kein
problem oder über nacht und dann nimmt
er ihn raus geräte team für ein paar
sekunden noch mal weich aber auch
wirklich nur ein paar sekunden und dann
geht es auch schon ganz ausrollen
da habe ich immer zwei methoden entweder
nämlich ein backpapier legen da meine
zwei auswahl stehen drauf die garantien
mir dass meine kekse gleich dick sind
die habe ich übrigens aus dem baumarkt
für sehr wenig geld statt die ihr für
sehr viel geld online zu kaufen
und ja dann lege ich dir einfach daneben
gibt da noch mal backpapier drüber und
soll das ganze aus
[Musik]
anschließend können dann aus dem teig
beliebige motive ausgestochen werden
[Musik]
für die zweite ausrollen methode gebe
ich einfach etwas mehl auf die
arbeitsfläche aber auch nicht zu viel
also nun dass es so ganz dünnen benetzt
ist gäbe dann den teig darauf wolle dass
ihr damit um einen austausch leben aus
und dann kann ich da auch wieder die
motive ausstechen
[Musik]
die keks rohlinge kommen dann auf ein
mit backpapier ausgelegtes backblech das
gebe ich dann für zehn minuten in den
kühlschrank dieser schritt ist sehr
wichtig damit die kekse auch nicht zu
erlaufen und schön ihre form beibehalten
und direkt aus dem kühlschrank kommen
sie dann in den vorgeheizten backofen
bei 190 grad ober und unterhitze für
zwölf minuten
und selbst gebackene kekse schmecken
einfach immer viel besser als gekaufte
und wer jetzt noch sehen möchte was aus
diesen keksen hübsches geworden ist der
kann auf das video rechts klicken
vielen dank fürs zu sehen und abonnieren
nicht vergessen bis zum nächsten mal auf
welches kitchen